if you're the lottery winner when you're
five yeah yeah and you win that golden
power ticket 500 million Jami when
you're five years old and it's all made
then you don't have to imagine that you
growing up it ruined your life like
listen little Tommy you never have to
work again it would ruin your life
you're talking about grandpa bought you
a lottery ticket when you were five yeah
if you'd be so nice to give us some of
that money that would be nice but you
have seven hundred and ninety million
dollars like what grandpa yeah grandpa
put it in a trust it's all yours and you
can have it yeah when you turn 18 but
you could give us some of it now you'd
be [ __ ]
growing up being like Richie Rich yeah
you'd be a mess you'd be like what the
[ __ ] be a mess you know a face full of
cocaine chasing this feelings that you
can't get just from practical everyday
work remember that cartoon Richie Rich
oh yeah his comic books every day that
every hit the Jersey sure I get his
comic books he always had new ones
that's got to be one of the weirdest
cartoons of all time a really rich kid
really went all the money in the world
well all the poor kids would read it and
go [ __ ] I wish I was Richie Rich man
this guy's got everything he's known
go-kart look at him see you there he's
got bachelors he's got a sundae
chocolates I want my little dear boy
comfy while he takes a nap teehee and he
says oh well thanks mom thanks ring over
candy and there's a butler dressed like
that dude with the tail coat
coincidentally but look at his butt look
at it look at the name of it it's Richie
Rich the poor little rich boy right
that's what it was the more a little
rich boy because he's not a hero because
he's not happy right look he's really
sad well first of all look at the size
of his ankles check out for sure but the
dude who's got the ice cream sundae he's
the same dress the same as go back to
the picture please the dude with the ice
cream sundae is in the very top yeah
he's wearing the same clothes that we
were mocking those oh that's right get
up eighteen hundred's get up see I used
to think about a guy like that like in
the shining or something like that yeah
there's
Butler and I would think of oh that's a
proper man that's a man that he's the
guy from the shining and he's just kind
of come over and be proper be a normal
normal but then as I got older I
realized like oh no no no that's a guy
it's just a guy and this guy is this
fucked-up job whereas to dress like he
lives in another time period and then
wait on all these rich white people like
what in the it's a tortured man right
there if you were a serious black rapper
like one of them guys with diamond teeth
wouldn't you get a diamond old white
servant like that guy all white Butler's
yes just like super super high yeah
professionals it's true I don't think
he's a professional but no sir
I love diamond teeth yeah yeah little
Richie Rich he wasn't happy Cadbury
Cadbury's Butler bring over that sundae
look at that other poor kid he's all
deformed and [ __ ] he looks like he's
evolving another kid looks like his
grandparents Richie Rich just like I'll
show you what it's like to be a rich
rich rich rich rich never had these
Neanderthal looking fella I never sat at
a table before maybe that blow that
picture that kid again out tell me he
doesn't look me into tall ass he has a
monkey face skin straight up does he
does he's got totaled Neanderthal things
Lalo isn't quite big enough but they
definitely gave him some odd features he
does look he's got bald patch the back
of his head was he had a bullet wound
scalp him rich cadbury and his friend
[ __ ]
girlfriends he's got all these comic it
is look at all the girls
yeah that is hilarious if the bills I so
it was one of them his mom the lady with
the blonde
here's his mom right a lot of her name
oh but the great with the blonde here's
his mom right a lotta little otter a lot
of a lot of their names are written down
oh Christ they're all his girlfriend's
little lot I get it she's big you get it
I'm not I'm I swear to god I'm having
flashbacks from every summer as a child
I'd go to this bookstore in their pee
comic books and I buy these little rich
yeah Richie Rich comic books and go home
and read them look he's looking at his
shadow
it's his a dollar sales free shadow when
it when he's got a rap girlfriend when
is a badass rapper gonna recreate this
picture for the covers album I think
that would be perfect for like Gucci
Mane Richie Richie oh come on tell me
that wouldn't be have him walk away cuz
he's okay he might have already done it
cuz it takes a lot of pictures of his
lovely wife that would be a perfect
picture for gucci mane and his wife
honey dollar bill behind him
holla dollar bill y'all took a change
it's so weird right what a crazy idea
for a comic strip Bay Area rapper named
Richie Rich so oh there you go
yeah I don't remember being like you
weren't really sending a message like
money isn't important awesome when you
want to be Richie always there always
getting ice cream Cadbury the perfect
Butler
frightfully fits oh yes mrs. rich one
should keep fit I exercise all the time
how interesting
that's literally the lines that the
comedy the size of her arms oh they're
like ham hock like she just mounts you
and just wraps your head up in those
arms and smothers you to death you try
to chew your way out but you run out of
air flaps get over here and if she's
ever in trouble she could literally leap
off a building with those things just
glide to safety
back in Jack's office
the left he's checked he's going into a
hot tub he's got a towel on and no shirt
he's ripped
when did Cadbury became so and look at
him what a butler whoa homoerotic yeah
what about so strange wait a minute
you're putting your Oh God look what he
says there gosh I've been keeping you
from your bath Cadbury I'm sorry please
go no need for biology sir someday I
shall relate this story of how I was
once lost all my clothes at the South
Pole and they says what up Butler as
he's walking him walk away with his tiny
little towel around his junk look a
little that towel is where do you even
find a towel that little that makes it
way all the way around your ass yeah you
covered your dick are you covering your
[ __ ] but you definitely not covered
both what can a strange snake-like towel
are you possessing six inches across
twelve feet long
yeah Cadbury got on the juice started
lifting got a fitness coach it's so
funny that was very homoerotic it was
weird
they were allowed to do weird stuff back
then magic you had that cartoon today
[ __ ] feds would show up at your door
yeah hey Tom papa
let's see your [ __ ] hard drive
another one of the pedophile conspiracy
creepy piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you been up to